je les ai
surpris c'était à midi il s'en allaient
elle est arrivée par derrière lui et lui
a volé un baiser dans le coup et dès
qu'elle avait le dos tourné Franck s'est
essuyé d'un revers de la main d'un air
un peu des dins ou de dégoût bon c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sûr été 2004 la fête basson plein sur la
Martinique une somptueuse péniche à
marée sur la scène à côté de
Paris ce soir-là les invités se pressent
autour des propriétaires des lieux Jean
et Dominique
aubr un couple d'antiire réputé et
fortuné à qui tout semble sourire et qui
mène la belle vie seulement cela ne va
pas
[Musique]
durer c'est l'histoire du tragique
destin d'un couple
fusionnel l'histoire d'un suicide qui
soulève bien des questions et celle d'un
énorme héritage qui forcément a suscité
l'envie une affaire incroyable où le
principal témoin n'est autre qu'un chien
elle était à quelques centimètres du sol
1 cm de plus elle était sauvée il y a ce
chien qui est là qui a passé c'est la
nuit là témoin involontaire de la mort
de sa
maîtresse l'app mon petit gigot
hériterait de la totalité ses 14
millions
d'euros il va découvrir une légère
fracture du larinx il ne s'agit pas d'un
suicide qu'il s'agit d'un
assassinat ça signe un acharnement
[Musique]
judiciaire prier décembre 2005 à ne une
banlieu chic de
Paris ici les bords de la scène abritent
d'immensees péniche transformé en riche
habitation il est 14h30 franc renard
païen 36 ans a rendez-vous pour déjeuner
avec son ami dominiic auri 57 ans
elle vit sur cette péniche qui est une
péniche de plusieurs centaines
00 ou 400 m c'est un
house très volumineux très massif
vraiment quelque chose c'est pas pas une
petite pénichette hollandaise c'est
vraiment le bâtiment Fran est surpris
car visiblement Dominique n'est pas là
étrange car il avait rendez-vous avec
elle
nouvre pas la porte elle ne répond pas
ses
appels du coup il s'inquiète va voir le
voisin et il sait que ce voisin dispose
à la fois du bip et des clés pour
rentrer sur la péniche le voisin nous
l'avons retrouvé il s'appelle Gabriel
voidet don clés il est parti et quelques
secondes après enfin le temps d'aller
là-bas il est revenu en courant en
hurlant et il est tellement paniqué
qu'il est incapable de de sortir le
moindre son de sa bouche j'ai dit mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe il y a pas le feu
il me dit viens viens
viens et effectivement quand je suis
allé sur le bateau j'ai vu en ouvrant la
porte Dominique qui était accroché après
l'escalier colimaçon par une
[Musique]
corde
alors je dois avouer que
j'étais très ému très très
bouleversé immédiatement le voisin
prévient la
police une équipe du commissariat de ne
sur scène arrive quelques instants plus
tard sur place les enquêteurs évidemment
interroge immédiatement la personne qui
les a appelé et Fran renard paayen
puisque c'est lui qui a découvert le
corps ilsous ont demandé comment ça
s'est passé on sait pas on leur a
expliqué qu'on était arrivé que je lui
avais donné les clés et que on était
revenu tous les deux et que on l'avait
vu comme ça que on n pas osé y toucher
quoi
euh semble semblait malheureusement
comme on dit morte quoi les policiers
pénètre à leur tour dans la
péniche le capitaine qui qui s'occupe de
cette affaire il est immédiatement
frappé bluffé scotché par la le luxe
qu'il voit dans cette dans cet habitat
ça vaut une fortune il sait qu'il qu'il
est face à une fortune il y avait des
objets magnifiques c'était que des
belles pièces oui il y avait des meubles
somptueux par vraiment d'AM musé
flottant il y a ce corps qu'on distingue
il y a ces objets luxueux il y a ce
chien qui est là qui a passé la nuit là
un joli dalmatien et cette pauvre femme
qui est morte probablement depuis
quelques heures déjà le chien était
resté toute la nuit avec sa
maîtresse dans la péniche c'est lui qui
était le témoin si on peut dire
involontaire de de la mort de sa
maîtresse Dominique auri Libé pour ses
amis était
antiire les enquêteurs interrogent le
premier témoin Fran renard païen celui
qui a découvert le cor et ce qu'il va
leur raconter va conforter la thèse du
suicide car Dominique avait apparemment
de bonnes raisons de mettre fin à ses
jours une femme qui ne se remet pas du
décès de son époux avec lequel elle une
relation fusionnelle en effet Jean aub
le mari de Dominique est décédé 10 mois
plus tôt dans des conditions
particulièrement tragique à l'âge de 60
ans il revenait de voyage au tout début
janvier 2005 il revenait de l'Î Maurice
et et c'est alors même qu'il se
trouvaient dans l'avion tous les deux
que je a fait une crise
cardiaque résultat elle a terminé son
voyage assis à côté de son mari mort et
est caché sous une couverture elle perd
son mari qui est assis à côté d'elle
dans l'avion sa vie s'écroule
elle était inconsolable la mort subite
de de cet homme de son mari qui était un
riche antiire un marchand de un marchand
d'art a été un véritable cataclysme dans
sa vie alors Dominique auri s'est-elle
suicidé car elle était incapable de
vivre sans l'homme auquel elle était
mariée depuis 40
ans l'hypothèse paraît probable
elle était vraiment très touché
moi je disais toujours elle a perdu son
son pig Malion par que il faisit tout
ensemble un de ses amis clairement dit
elle pouvait pas vivre après le décès de
Jean c'était c'était difficile de
l'avir dans cet état là quoi ça me
nuisait un petit peu tous les jours quoi
en une ou deux question les policiers
sentendent répondre que elle était
suicidaire c'était un secret visiblement
pour
personne à première vue dominiic auri
avait toutes les raisons de mettre fin à
ses jours
et d'ailleurs lorsque les policiers vont
faire les constatations
d'usage ils ne vont rien trouver qui
puisse prouver le
contraire une petite femme qui avait la
tête penchée sur la gauche avec un
cordage bleu autour du cou cette corde
bleue est identique à celle utilisée sur
le pont de la péniche
elle est solidement accrochée à la 11e
marche de
l'escalier
ce que j'ai remarqué tout de suite c'est
qu'elle était à quelques centimètres du
du sol et quand elle s'est pendue après
cette corde le nœud a dû se
détendre 1 cm de plus elle était
sauvé à première vue aucune trace de
lutte ou de
cambriolage seul deux chaises sont
renversées au pied de la dépouille de
domin
au tout le reste de la maison est en
parfait état parfait état de propreté de
rangement il y a juste sur la table
basse deux plaquettes vides de de
somnifè un flacon de vide de l'exomy et
un verre avec une poudre séchée au fond
de ce verre comme si on avait dissous
des médicaments et qu'il restait un un
fond de médicaments ce qui laisse à
penser qu'elle aurait pu prendre
beaucoup beaucoup de cachets avant de
mourir tout laisse donc penser que
Dominique auri s'est suicidé même si la
victime n'a pas laissé de mot
d'adieu toutefois il y a un petit détail
qui ne colle pas elle avait des mèche de
cheveux à l'intérieur de la corde ce qui
semble-t-il est une particularité rare
chez les gens qui se
pendent le corps de dominiic auri est
décroché pour être
autopsié et les médecins vont apporter
semble-t-il des preuves que la riche
veuve s'est belelle et bien
suicidé d'abord d'après les légistes la
victime était ivre lors de sa pandaison
elle avait 2 g 44 d'alcool dans le sang
et ce n'est pas tout Domini avait aussi
pris des médicaments des anxiolitiques
et des somnifères qui correspondent aux
emballages découverts sur la table du
salon les experts toxicologues ont
souligné le fait que la prise de
médicaments avant une pandaon était
relativement fréquente parce que ça a
aidait au passage à
[Musique]
l'acte tout l'air d'un suicide en tous
les cas enfin conclu qu'il y a aucune
trace de violence et qu'elle est
morte par suffocation par cette
parasfixi à cause de cette
pendaison au commissariat de ne sur scè
une simple enquête pour recherche des
causes de la mort est ouverte comme il
est d'usage en cas de suicide celui qui
a découvert le corps de la victime est
entendu le soir même Franck renard païen
et donc auditionné ils ont besoin de de
recueillir ses explications la relation
qu'il a avec elle qui il est par rapport
à elle il va raconter qu'ils sont amis
depuis au moins 17 ans en gros païen et
et cette femme ont une relation très
très forte
d'ailleurs Monsieur et Madame auri ont
considéré païen comme leur fils adoptif
il était considéré comme le fils
spirituel du du couple auri qui n'avait
donc jamais eu d'enfant et il a été
toujours plus présent au côté de
Dominique Aubri dès lors que Jean Aubri
est mort très ému Franck renardpayen
raconte au policier être le dernier à
avoir vu Dominique auri en vie c'était
la veille au soir Franck renard paayen
avait dé avec dominiic Aubri il avait
dîné sur la péniche il est arrivé vers
18h30 ils ont bu quelques verre et puis
ensuite ils ont mangé rapidement il y
avait du poulet au menu de la salade euh
et quand dessert il aurait mangé une
Danette le tout arrosé bien sûr et il
est parti
euh vers 21h30 dit-il à peu près à 21h30
Franck ronarpayen quitte donc la péniche
laissant son ami seul chez elle il
explique n'avoir rien remarqué de
spécial et rendez-vous est pris pour
déjeuner ensemble le
lendemain c'est à cette occasion qu'il
est revenu
au alentours de 13h30 14h il a
carillonné qu'il l'a appelé qu'elle ne
répondait pas qu'il a été chercher les
clés qu'il est rentré dans la péniche
après avoir raconté les faits Fran
ronardpayen va révéler au policiers une
information importante concernant son
ami Dominique
elle avait déjà fait une tentative de
suicide au mois de juillet 6 mois
auparavant sur cette même péniche des
médicaments qu'elle avait pris c'était
d'ailleurs lui qui l'avait pour les
policiers le dossier semble relativement
simple et relativement limpide
relativement clair cette femme a perdu
son mari il y a 10 mois elle a sombré
dans l'alcool elle fait une dépression
nerveuse elle a tenté de se suicider et
elle a fini par par y parvenir aux yeux
de tous dominiic au BRI a donc mis fin
ses jours l'affaire est
classée seulement voilà très vite des
révélations inattendues vont venir
remettre en cause la tèse du suicide de
Dominique
[Musique]
au en effet le soir même de la
découverte du corps de la riche veuve le
commissariat de ne sur scè reçoit un
étrange appel
téléphonique il y a un notaire qui
téléphone pour dire il y a un testament
voilà il va raconter que le dossier de
succession va être complexe compliqué et
que l'héritier le légataire
universel de Dominique au se trouve être
Fran renard
païen et d'après le notaire l'héritage
est
colossal Fran renard païen hériterait de
la totalité et la totalité c'est pas
rien c'est 14 millions
d'euros 14 millions d'euros auquel se
rajoute près d'un million d'assurance
vie soit près de million d'euros au
profit d'un unique héritier Franck
renard païen cet homme qui souvenez-vous
est le dernier à avoir vu la victime
vivante et qui a ensuite découvert son
corps dans l'esprit d'un policier un
esprit suspicieux a raison il se dit
mais voilà ça cache quelque chose à
partir de là il y a deux possibilités
soit fidèle aux apparences il s'agit
d'un su
soit c'est un crime qui a été maquillé
en
suicide alors qui est vraiment franc
renard
païen les policiers vont se pencher sur
sa vie et font un premier constat à 36
ans l'homme a un casier judiciaire
vierge Fran c'est un fils de très bonne
famille le père est magistrat haut
magistrat très haut magistrat même
puisquil est allé il a sa carrière à la
Cour de cassation sa mère est médecin
euh ses frères et sœurs sont financiers
pour l'un avocat pour l'autre ils ont
fait de brillantes études mais alors
Franck il a pas fait de brillantes
études du tout il a pas de diplôme avéré
il a jamais eu de vrais métier c'est un
peu un fils à papa un enfant gâté qui
profite de son physique de ses bonnes
manières et de cette espèce
d'aristocratie visible d'ailleurs he sur
le personnage pour mener une
vie une vie plutôt douce agréable et
festive il fait pas solide il fait assez
instable et assurément hyper sensible il
a une forme de marginalité
mondaine c'est dans une boîte de nuit
hupé de la capitale que Franck renard
paayen fait la connaissance de Dominic
BRI et de son époux
Jean très mondain le couple d'antiire
était de toutes les
fêtes régulièrement ils recevaient sur
leur grande péniche où rien n'était
jamais trop beau pour leurs
[Musique]
invités il est vrai qu'ils étaient
entourés de gens plus jeunes Jean et
Libé détestaient les gens de leur
vraiment de leurâ c'était il s'emmerdait
vraiment il fallait que ça bouge
Stanislas l roi faisait partie du cercle
proche de Dominique et Jean obbri et il
connaissait aussi très bien Franck
renard
païen Fran était vraiment oui quelqu'un
qui j'ai passé beaucoup de temps et qui
était un très très bon ami du couple un
très très grand ami il les a côtoyé
pendant pendant plus de 20 ans au fil du
temps Fran ronard paayen devient un
intime de ce couple sans enfants et donc
a priori rien de surprenant à ce que la
veuve Dominique auri en facee son unique
[Musique]
héritier ça m'étonnait pas du tout
qu'elle laisse à à franc son héritage il
y avait rien d'extraordinaire puisque
c'était le fils spirituel et c'est vrai
que tout le monde le
savait mais en réalité si Dominique auri
a fait de franc renard païen son
légataire universel c'est parce qu'elle
avait une bonne
raison depuis 2 ans elle était fâchée
avec son frère
Frédéric dominiic auri ne voulait rien
laisser à son frère elle aurait préféré
faire hériter son ch que faire hiter son
frère elle ne voulait absolument pas que
son frère touche quoi que ce soit
brouillé avec son frère Dominique auri
avait donc choisi un autre
héritier les enquêteurs ont donc une
explication qui finalement dédouine Fran
ronard païen le fils spirituel de la
riche veuve à ce stade de l'enquête
l'hypothèse du meurtre est donc écarté
il y a pas d'élément pour dire qu'elle a
été violentée y a rien pour dire qu'on
l'a accroché à la corde elle a voulu
donner son argent à franc renard païen
pourquoi pas après un gros mois
d'enquête le parquet de nanaire
considère qu'il y a rien dans ce dossier
rien de suspect et décide donc d'aller
vers un classement un classement sans
suite qui voudrait en fait confirmer
l'hypothèse du suicide mais en réalité
l'affaire de la mort de la riche veuve
n'en est qu'à ses
début
en effet un autre voisin de Dominique
auri qui vit sur une péniche proche va
faire une révélation de taille aux
enquêteurs la veille au soir Fran
n'était pas seul avec lib et qui avait
une trè personne étrange Fran renard
païen lors de son audition avait omis de
donner ce détail aux
[Musique]
enquêteur ici on un peu tileté en disant
mais pourquoi il nous a pas parlé de ce
copain plôt c'est bizarre entre la
fortune
l'héritage le fait d'omettre de de de
dire qui était présent au dernier moment
bon le le le doute commence à s'imisser
dans la tête des
enquêteurs Fran ronard paayen est une
nouvelle fois convoqué par les policiers
pour s'expliquer sur la présence d'un
mystérieux homme sur la péniche la
veille de la mort de
Dominic mais aussi sur l'héritage
colossal dont il est l'unique
bénéficière et la stupeur le jeune homme
paraî étonné il affirme ignorer être
l'unique légataire de son ami et
concernant la présence du deuxè invité
au dîner il a une explication
déroutante tout simplement parce qu'on
lui a pas posé la question les on pas
posé la question il pas dit pas dit
parce que parce qu'il était sonné parce
qu'il était sous le choc qu'il y a pas
pensé enfin c'était ça lui a pas paru
important à
dire durant la suite de l'interrogatoire
les policiers questionnent Franck renard
païen sur ce mystérieux ami présent sur
la
péniche il s'appelle Olivier Hustache 34
ans il est sans emploi le stage c'est
pas le même profil le stage il vient pas
du même milieu Stach il s'est fabriqué à
la force des poignets il a pas eu de
père ou en tout cas un père absent il a
fait des études euh poussé
sérieuse il est pas il fait pas très fun
Olivier fait assez strict rigide voire
rigide voilà et et lui par contre il a
commencé à travailler comme ingénieur il
a monté des
sociétés il a versé dans la finance les
placement mais alors lui aussi à un
moment il s'est arrêté c'estàd qu'au
moment où il rencontre Franck après son
divorce il travaill
d'après Franck Olivier et lui seraiit
devenu inséparable comme deux
frères et régulièrement les deux hommes
venaient rendre visite à Dominico
BRI tous les trois passaient de bons
moments ils vont sortir ensemble ils
vont rire ensemble beaucoup rire
ensemble et puis ils vont se retrouver
là dans quelque chose qui ne ressemble
pas c'est vrai à des amitiés bourgeoises
codifié avec Fran renard paayen et
olivierach
Domini se laissait aller à boire la
riche veuve pouvait ainsi oublier un
instant le désespoir
qu'hitait c'est un peu hor norme mais
ils sont atypiqu ces TR là sont atypi la
personnalité de Dominique au apparaî
plus
complexe une femme qui n'hésitait pas à
utiliser son argent pour vaincre sa
solitude et Fran renard païen
etivierach prof allr de la gosité de la
riche veuve elle avait une telle avidité
de de ne pas être seule une telle
crainte de de la solitude qu'elle était
prête à être très généreuse pour ne pas
être seule et ce n'est pas tout au fil
de l'audition de franc renard païen
Dominique auri apparaît sous un jour
plus sombre une femme généreuse certes
mais qui en échange pouvait se montrer
tyrannique considérait même par moment
que dans la mesure où c'était qui paye
franc qui n'a qu'à se taire et faire
comme elle veut et comme elle dit et
c'est tout quoi si on n'avait pas pour
son argent pour le dire vulgairement sa
barder alors les deux hommes Franck et
Olivier auraient-ils profité du
désespoir de leur riche ami au point de
la tuer c'est ce que les enquêteurs
soupçonnent lorsque 15 jours après le
drame ils convoque le mystérieux
Hostache au commissariat de
ne
il confirme avoir dîné la veille avec
Franck et Dominique sur la pénig il a
été question du des prochaines vacances
puisque Dominique aubr programmait tout
le temps des vacances au Club
Med très régulièrement elle partait elle
dépensait beaucoup d'argent pour les
vacances pour les siennes et pour celles
aussi de franc déjà elle voulait partir
avec eux au Sénégal parce que c'était un
club ma où elle allait avec son mari je
crois que c'était le Cap Skiring et les
deux garçons trouvaient que c'était un
peu ringard que c'était fréquenté par
des golfeurs et qui trouvaient pas ça
très fun et qu'ils auraient préféré un
lieu plus festif alors peut-être de
façon désinvolte un petit peu peut-être
sans doute d'ailleurs ils lui ont dit
non on n pas envie d'aller là tu nous
embêtes elle l'a très mal pris ce
soir-là totalement ivre dominiic auri
serait devenu de plus en plus
désagréable
[Musique]
elle est devenue un petit peu un petit
peu difficile à gérer et du coup ils
sont partis assez tôt puisqueà 21h30 ils
avaient quitté les lieux si l'on en
croit les déclarations d'Olivier
austache ce dernier dîner aurait tourné
court et ce n'est pas tout ce que le
jeune homme va révéler à la
police les policiers vont tenter à un
moment donné de déstabiliser Olivier
aostache en évoquant l'histoire du
testament en lui disant est-ce que vous
étiez au courant qu'en cas de décès euh
votre ami Franck renard paayen allait
hériter de la totalité de la fortune de
Dominique auri et Olivier répond que oui
il est au courant parfaitement au
courant non seulement Olivier eustach
était au courant mais il avoue aux
enquêteurs qu'il a participé à la
rédaction du dit testament avec
Dominique auri comme j'ai fait les
études de droit je l'ai aidé à
rédiger ce testament qu'elle modifiait
il précise même qu'il a lui-même
accompagné Dominique auri chez le
notaire
et non seulement il a accompagné à
l'étude du notaire mais il était dans le
bureau assis à côté d'elle au moment où
les papiers ont été
signés les enquêteurs sont
stupéfaits 2 mois avant leseffit 2 mois
avant la mort de Dominique auri il va
lui l'aider alors qu'il a connaît depuis
4 mois à rédigé le testament holographe
c'est vrai que ça peut paraître suspect
pour un enquêteur de chevronet d'autant
plus suspect que Franck celui qui
présente Olivier eustach comme son
meilleur ami a toujours prétendu ne pas
être au courant de l'existence d'un
testament en sa
faveur à la lumière de ces incohérences
la piste criminelle semble de plus en
plus
envisageable 14 millions ça peut quand
même représenter un mobile puis un
mobile de poids si je puis dire 14
millions d'euros euh peut faire naître
des vocations criminelles suicide ou
assassinat que s'est-il réellement passé
dans le huit cllos de cette péniche le
soir du 30 novembre
2005 la police est soupçonneuse et elle
n'est pas la seule car deux personnes
elles aussi ont plus que des dotes sur
la thèse du
[Musique]
suicide
frédéric est le frère de dominiic au
accompagné de sa mère les deux vont
déposer une plainte en disant qu'il ne
s'agit pas d'un suicide qu'il s'agit
assassinat et ils on des arguments ils
disent d'abord que Dom donc que n'était
pas suicidaire la veille de mort ellea
appel sa mère elle était en pleine forme
elle devait s'appeler le
sur d'prè
domaitjets de voy allait mieux depuis
qu'elle avait entamé une relation
amoureuse avec un homme rencontré
quelques temps avant sa mort et pour la
théorie de la pendaison c'est impossible
car d'après sa famille Dominique était
incapable de se servir de ses deux mains
elle était tellement maladroite cette
femme qu'elle aurait été incapable de
faire des nœuds aussi sophistiqués pour
se pendre je crois que même pas qu' elle
arrivait à attacher le c'est même pas un
nœud c'est juste mettre la corde autour
du taquet du Riva c'était déjà compliqué
elle est pas
manuelle en gros elle savait rien faire
toute seule c'est pas possible or les
policiers l'ont observé dans leur
constatation le nœud d'attachche de la
corde était particulièrement
élaboré pour la famille de Dominique
auri c'est donc quelqu'un d'autre qui a
fabriqué le nœud de
pendaison
à la suite de la plainte de la famille
de Dominique de nouveaux témoignages
vont faire rebondir
l'enquête les policiers entendent de
nouveau les témoins qui vivent sur le
même quai il raconte avoir remarqué
quelque chose d'étrange le matin du
drame quelques heures avant la
découverte du corps les voisins avait vu
une chose importante c'est que la
passerelle de la péniche était baissée
c'est endroit où il y a effectivement
des œuvres qui valent des prix sûement
exorbitant donc le pourlev était
un réflexe à peu près systématique
c'était toujours relevé bien entendu de
la vie de tous dominiic au remontait
systématiquement la passerelle de la
péniche de peur des
cambriolages ce qui veut dire en gros
que si la passerelle est
baissée les assassins
quitent la péniche après avoir commis
leur forfait mais ils n'ont plus les
moyens techniques de faire relever la
passerelle puisqu'il faut un bip et
qu'il y en a qu'un et qui est à
l'intérieur de la péniche et par
conséquent ils ont pas le choix que de
laisser la passerelle
abaisser à la suite de la plainte de la
famille de dominiic au le parquet est
saisi le 31 janvier 2006 une information
judiciaire est ouverte contre X pour
assassinat ils sont convaincus que leur
sœur ou fille a été tué que le meurtre a
été prémédité et si la la plainte est
déposée contre X il est évident qu'elle
vise directement Fran renard
païen la succession de dominiic auri au
profit de Franck renard païen est
suspendu une nouvelle enquête
redémarre cette fois ce n'est plus le
commissariat de quartier de ne mais la
brigade criminelle de Paris qui sera
saisi par le premier juge d'instruction
du 109 va se pencher sur le dossier
d'abord les nouveaux enquêteur se Pench
sur la personnalité de la victime cétait
un petit bout de femme qui était qui
était pas mal qui
était
pétillante agréable quoi excessivement
drôle quand elle avait un tout petit peu
qui aimait la vie qui aimait s'amuser
qui aimait rire qui aimait chanter qui
aimait danser qui aimait boire qui
aimait s'amuser qui aimait aller en
vacances après de longues recherches les
policiers retrouvent son dernier amant
Didier 55 ans rencontré 6 mois plus tôt
lors de vacances en
Tunisie l'homme est immédiatement
entendu par les policiers et il garde le
souvenir d'une femme très exigeante
envers
elle-mêmeis beaucoup de gym d'ailleurs
elle avait une salle de gym à faire
rêver quelques quelques salles de
parisiennes selt 1,65 peut-être 36 de
pantalons quoi pour son âge bon il y a
rien à dire là-dessus toujours élégante
mais ce qui intéresse le plus les
policiers c'est la nature des relations
entre Franck renard païen et Libé Franck
il discuté un petit peu avec elle de de
choses et d'autres quand est-ce qu'on va
à rue Montaigne pour voilà parce parce
que je sais que il se faisait payer des
jeans à 500 € il aimait bien et puis
elle aussi parce que ça lu faisait une
petite sortie
elle l'appelé mon petit gigolo à
plusieurs reprises he je sais que c'est
mon petit gigolo c'est c'est elle même
qui l'appelait comme ça si Dominique
jouait volontiers avec son jeune ami en
revanche Franck de son côté gardait ses
distances je les ai
surpris c'était à midi il s'en allait
elle est arrivée par derrière lui et lui
a volé un baiser dans le cou et dès
qu'elle avait le dos tourné Franck s'est
essuyé d'un revers de la main d'un air
un peu dédin ou de dégoût bon c'est sûr
mais après l'audition de Didier rien ne
permet de dire que Franck renard païen
soit impliqué dans la mort de Dominique
auri 6 mois après le décès de la riche
veuve l'enquête donc au point mort la
question est de savoir si Dominique auri
a pu se pendre seul après le départ de
ses
amis le juge ordonne donc une
reconstitution en juillet 2006 il y a
une première reconstitution qui est
faite donc avec avec un mannequin donc
le but est de vérifier si oui ou non il
était possible pour Dominique aub de se
pendre elle-même avec 2 g 44 d'alcool
dans le sang et après avoir absorbé des
médicaments
même si c'est ad thérapeutique mélanger
à l'alcool ça peut quelquefis faire des
choses étonnantes est-ce qu'elle est
capable d'une part d'aller accrocher sa
corde à la 11e marche 2
M33 de redescendre de monter en
équilibre sur une ou de chaises on
retrouve de par terre s'accrocher se
pendre et jeter les chaises avec ce taux
d'alcool dans le sang on peut pas se
pendre on peut pas faire un nœud bon
d'abord le nœud il a pu être fait avant
l'ivresse
ensuite on a des tas d'exemples en
particulier en matière de délinquence
routière de gens qui conduisent avec des
taux supérieur à celui-là le mannequin
n'a pas bu de GR 44 d'alcool mais
enfin mais finalement cette
reconstitution ne permet pas de conclure
un
scénario précis et permet pas de dire
oui c'est possible non c'est
impossible 2 ans après la disparition de
Dominique auri la justice ne parvient
pas à tranché c'est-elle donné la mort
ou Fran ronardpayen l'aurait-il tué avec
l'aide de son ami Olivier
Hach en 2008 un nouveau juge reprend le
dossier il veut des résultats le
magistrat va ordonner une nouvelle
autopsie qui va faire apparaître un
élément incroyable que le médecin
légiste n'avait pas vu la première fois
il va
découvrir selon
lui une fracture légère fracture du
larinx normalement un larinx de
quelqu'un qui s'est pendu il y a pas de
le larinx se ce pas en revanche quand on
étrangle les gens c'est classique il y a
y a une blessure d'où la conclusion des
experts ah ben elle a été
étranglée aussitôt l'enquête
redémarre le juge ordonne de nouvelles
analyses ADN de tous les cellés de la
scène de crime et en particulier sur la
corde au bout de laquelle Dominic s
pendu et un premier résultat va
surprendre tout le
monde on a retrouvé l'ADN de lib
uniquement à l'intérieur du nœud coulant
avec lequel qui a provoqué sa mort on
s'est demandé pourquoi on n pas retrouvé
laadn de lib sur le long de la corde
comment la victime a-t-elle pu manipuler
la
la fixer à l'escalier régler la longueur
faire un nœud coulant et un nœud d'arrêt
sans y laisser son ADN de nouvelles
analyses vont apporter une réponse les
hommes de la police technique et
scientifique vont découvrir des traces
d'ADN masculine sur le haut de la cord
c'est au niveau de la marche de la 11e
marche et cette ADN n'est pas inconnu on
a retrouvé de l'ADN quiostache sur la
partie haute de la corde et ce n'est pas
tout on va analyser un autre tronçon de
corde qui est le tronçon du bas
c'est-à-dire au niveau du nœud coulant
qui enserrait le coup de dominicob et on
va retrouver l'ADN d'Olivier aostache
encore l'ADN d'un des deux hommes
présents lors du dernier dîner de la
victime un rapport d'autopsie qui parle
d'étranglement le tout sur un fond
d'héritage
colossal dès lors Franck renard paen et
Olivier aostache deviennent les deux
suspects du possible assassinat de
dominiic
aubr le 28 mai 2008 les deux hommes sont
interpellés à l'aube à leur domicile
respectif dans les locaux de la police
judiciaire de Versailles les gardes à vu
commencent c'est simplement la nécessité
de les placer dans une situation
extrêmement critique de stress aigu pour
voir s'il n'allait pas en ressortir
quelque chose de nouveau mais les deux
hommes ni farouchement toute implication
dans la mort de Dominique auri ils
affirment qu'elle était bien vivante
lorsqu'ils ont quitté la
péniche Fran renard paayen maintient ses
déclarations il ignorait l'unique
héritier de Libé et cela même si son
meilleur ami Olivier hustach avait
rédigé ce testament avec la victime
elle-même Franck renard paayen il est
bouleversé il est
perdu il répond aux questions qu'on lui
pose il il n'envisage pas un instant je
suppose qu'on pourrait l'accuser d'un
crime qui plusé d'avoir assassiné celle
qui était finalement sa meilleure
amie les interrogatoires se succèdent et
Olivier hustach est confronté au
résultat des expertises qu' l'AC CABL
comment se fait-il que son ADN soit
présent sur la corde au bout de laquelle
on a retrouvé la victime mais l'homme a
une
explication cette corde à l'évidence
elle est pas une corde neuve il y avait
des cordes partout
et stage dit à l'extérieur il m'est
arrivé de toucher des cordes parfois il
s'amusait à
accrocher une corde au bout du bateau et
à se
balancer pour jouer à Tarzan n'était pas
un normal qu' ait leur ADN partout
puisque il fréquentaient ce lieu et ce
n'est pas tout les avocats d'Olivier
aache vont remettre en cause l'enquête
des policiers qui visiblement n'ont pas
travaillé sur cette affaire avec la
rigueur qui s'impose le problème de
cette cte si vous voulez c'est qu'elle a
été tripotée par tout le monde parce que
les policiers n'avaient pas de gant
parce qu'on pensait à ce moment-là qu'il
s'agissait d'un suicide qui év une
espèce de raison de prendre des
précautions alors on retrouve l'ADN
d'Olivier aostache certes mais au milieu
de de très nombreux ADN masculin et
féminin pendant la reconstitution on a à
nouveau manipulé et on voit d'ailleurs
un certain nombre de photographies d'une
stagiaire qui sur l'initiative à
l'initiative du jugeinstruction touche
la corde avant le résultat des
expertises ADN donc voilà le sérieux
avec lequel ça a été fait seulement les
arguments d'olivier tâche ne suffisent
pas à convaincre le juge
d'instruction après 48 heures de garde-
à vue les deux hommes sont mis en examen
pour assassinat et immédiatement
[Musique]
incarcéré convaincu de leur culpabilité
le juge d'instruction va s'attacher
maintenant à rassembler des éléments
pour prouver l'implication des deux
[Musique]
suspects et très vite c'est un expert
qui va venir abonder dans le sens de la
justice
voici ses
[Musique]
conclusions l'imprégnation alcoolique et
médicamenteuse rend très hypothétique le
fait que la victime a eu la force et
l'habileté manuelle suffisante pour
constituer un nœud renverser l'appui et
se laisser pendre avec les pieds
reposant au
[Musique]
sol
le décès de Madame auri nous paraît très
peu compatible voire impossible avec une
pendaison
suicidaire à la lumière de ces
conclusions le juge d'instruction
organise une nouvelle
reconstitution et cette fois-ci pour
tenter de confondre Fran ronard paayen
et Olivier aostache il a une botte
secrète le chien de la victime qui était
présent sur pénich au moment de la mort
de Dominique
aubr c'est-à-dire que les deux hommes
sont placés face au chien de Dominic obr
à Tho le dalmatien le juge d'instruction
a imaginé que si le chien avait assisté
à un éventuel crime il en garderait des
séquelles psychologiques le chien donc
on a examiné sur un plan psychologique
Tho
dalmatien pour savoir s'il allait réagir
mise en présence des suspects
tous les animaux ont une
mémoire qui est qui est bien connu il
souviennent des événements graves soit
qui les ont affectés soit qui ont
affecter la personne qu'ils
affectionneent il y a plusieurs
réactions possibles ou bien le chien va
attaquer ou bien le chien va aller se
cacher tout dépend de la réaction de
l'animal tout dépend de l'animal le
professeur vétérinaire il observe le
chien quand quand il sent le t-shirt
quand il se déplace à tel ou tel endroit
de la pénige quand il approche ou qu'il
approche pas de telle ou telle
personne et note des attitude
d'inquiétude ou pas des attitudes
d'inquiétude alors ce jour-là tout le
monde attend beaucoup de la réaction de
Théo le
dalmatien et face à Olivier aostache le
chien ne va pas rester insensible
il va même se montrer
inquiet Théo le chien devient ainsi le
témoin numéro 1 mais forcément ces
méthodes vétérinaires vont faire sourire
le milieu judiciaire au palais justice
de N l'affaire Dominique auri elle est
connue comme étant l'affaire du
chien qu'est-ce que ça veut dire le
signe de crainte ça veut dire que le
chien a peur il a peur de quoi
de recevoir un coup de pied ou il a peur
d'être à nouveau en présence d'un
assassin enfin c'est c'est c'est
n'importe quoi cette histoire c'est
n'importe quoi il y a des chiens qui
sont craintifs il y a des chiens qui
sont pas il y a des chiens qui mordent
les facteurs on a toujours pas compris
[Musique]
pourquoi face à un dossier fragile et
sans preuve indiscutable de leur
culpabilité les avocats obtiennent la
libération conditionnelle de leurs
clients Fran ronard paayen et Olivier
aostache sont donc libre mais reste mise
en examen pour
assassinat va alors suivre une bataille
d'expert 38 au total qui tous vont se
pencher sur cette question Dominique
Aurice est-elle oui ou non suicidé où
a-t-elle été assassinée par Franck
renard paayen et Olivier
aostache une instruction qui devient
folle avec une surmultiplication
d'expertise bon ça c'est c'est hornme
mais c'est du jamais vu 38 expertises
qui ont été ordonné dans cette procédure
c'est inédit dans les anales judiciaires
c'est que même pour un craque aérien on
n pas un tel volume d'expertise ça signe
une forme
d'acharnement enfin que dis-je c'est pas
une forme d'acharnement d'ailleurs ça
signe un acharnement
judiciaire et le moins que l'on puisse
dire c'est que les n expert désignés
vont rendre des
conclusions
mitigé concernant l'heure de la mort de
Dominic BR pour certains experts elle se
situe entre 20h et
23h mais pour d'autres une demi-heure
après le repas c'estàdire vers 21h au
moment où les deux suspects étaient
présents sur la
péniche et ce n'est pas tout la fracture
du larinx de la victime est aussi remise
en cause
pour certains légistes elle est la
preuve d'un étranglement mais pour
d'autres experts la fracture a pu être
faite lors de la dépendaison de dominiic
[Musique]
au dernier point de désaccord entre les
experts l'état de Dominico BRI lors de
sa
mort certains spécialistes soutiennent
qu'étant donné son taux d'alcool et les
médicaments qu'elle avait pris elle ne
pouvait pas se pendre seule d'autres
affirment le contraire
à entre au palais de justice le dossier
s'en
lise la succession de la riche veuve est
toujours bloquée mais l'affaire ne va
pas tarder à prendre une toute nouvelle
tournure 6 ans après la mort de dominiic
au ce juge qui a qui n'a pas ménagé sa
peine
pour résoudre l'énigme quit son poste
une autre juge va donc être nommée c'est
la trè
elle analyse à son tour les 6000 pages
du dossier et le 11 mai 2011 elle rend
des conclusions qui vont tout
bouleverser selon elle il y avait pas
d'élément à charge il y avait pas
d'élément suffisamment à charge en tout
cas pour justifier que ces deux hommes
soient renvoyés devant la Cour d'assise
pour un assassinat quand même voil donc
elle rend une ordonnance de nonlieu
7 ans après la mort de Dominique auri
les deux suspects Fran ronard paayen et
Olivier austache pensent en avoir
terminer avec la
justice mais les choses ne vont pas se
passer ainsi car le parquet va faire
appel de la décision du
[Musique]
juge d'autres juges qui se repenchent
sur le dossier qui relisent l'ensemble
et qui se font leur avis et là ils se
font un avis contraire à celui de la
juge
qui a rendu l'ordonnance de longlieu
puisquil rend eu un arrêt de renvoi
devant la Cour
d'acier désormais pour l'instruction
voici comment les choses se seraient
passé ce 30 novembre
2005 le soir du drame Fran renard paayen
et olivierach seraient venus dîner sur
la
[Musique]
péniche tout d'abord ils auraient drogué
Dominique au en lui faisant boire un
verre contenant des somnifères et des
anxiolitiques quelques instants plus
tard la riche veuve presque
inconsciente aurait été tué par
[Musique]
étranglement une fois qu'elle est
étranglée ils vont installer leur
système de
[Musique]
cordage et ils vont l'pporter renverser
les
chaise et puis ensuite mettre les
médicaments sur la table ranger ce qu'il
fallait ranger et puis
disparaître dans la
nuit toujours selon l'instruction en
quittant la péniche les deux hommes
auraient omis de remonter la
passerelle
le lendemain en début d'après-midi Fran
ronard paayen aurait fin la surprise en
découvrant son ami
pendu pour le reste le mobile semble
évident
l'argent Fran souhaite hériter au plus
vite de Dominique au de peur qu'elle ne
change
d'avis quant à Olivier aostache il
l'aurait aidé à réaliser le crime par
intérêt
[Musique]
le 4 mars
2014 le procès s'ouvre devant la Cour
d'Assise des hautes scèes à
nanter pour olivierach et Fran renard
païen qui comparaissent libr l'enjeu est
énorme ils encour la réclusion
criminelle à
perpétuité quand on a vu la justice
fonctionner comme elle fonctionne durant
cette
instruction pas être serein dans le box
Fran ronard paayen accablé par
l'accusation semble particulièrement
inqui et mal à
l'aise il se levait comme un enfant de
son siège quand autrefois les enfants se
levaient quand le maître les appelait il
met les deux mains derrière le dos il
fait il répond poliment oui monsieur non
monsieur avec une c'est oui presque un
enf
9 ans après la disparition de la riche
veuve de nei le mystère de sa mort reste
entier alors tout le monde attend le
procès pour avoir des réponses il s'est
ouvert avec un immense point
d'interrogation c'est-à-dire que
vraiment c'était le mystère
absolu suicide assassinat les deux
thèses étaient posé sur la table le
nombre des experts la la la
particularité de cette procédure fait
qu'effectivement on était en préson
à la barre les experts justement
enchaînent leur démonstration mais
aucune certitude ne se
dégage pire l'expert qui avait
formellement conclu un assassinat va
revenir sur ses conclusions et dans la
salle c'est la stupeur l'avocat
général un moment il en
a il a dit mais monsieur
l'expert j'ai l'impression que je ne
suis plus très en phase avec ce que vous
avez écrit ah oui c'est que l'expert est
venu dire le contraire de ce qu'il avait
écrit et comme ce qu'il avait écrit
fondait l'accusation c'est quand même
problématique problématique également le
défilé des témoins qui 9 ans après les
faits ne sont plus capables de dire si
la passerelle était abaissée ou levée
comme dans le reste du dossier on arrive
dans le flou il y en a qui disent oui il
y en a qui disent c'était peut-être la
veille il y a qui disent c'était
sûrement pas la
en fait on ne sait pas de façon formelle
la position de la
passerelle tout ça laisse à l'évidence à
la cour d'assise l'impression que on est
allé à la pêche aux attestations et
que très justement on ne saura jamais ce
qui a pu se passer ce procès qui est
vide de toute preuve c'est un dossier
d'ambiance un dossier d'impression
toujours est-il que tout ça n'a pas
empêché l'avocat
général même en présence de doutes de
requérir contre les deux amis Franck et
Olivier une peine allant de 15 à 20 ans
de réclusion
[Musique]
criminelle pendant plus de 3 He les
quatre avocats vont venir au secours de
leurs clients et demander d'acquitter
les deux hommes au bénéfice du
doute
si vous voulez c'est le genre de procès
où à la fin on se dit peut-être qu'ils
ont tué cette femme mais on peut de
toute façon pas le
prouver on n pas une preuve et le
verdict ne se fait pas
attendre à peine 3 He de
délibérer Fran renard paayen et Olivier
aostache ont été acquittés par la cour
d' de nanter après 2 he de
déli un instant plus tard les de hommes
peuvent sortir de la salle du tribunal
de
nanter
libre comment vous vous
sentez
libéré jeattends que ce soit confirmé
pas d'appel pas envie de revivre tout ça
j'ai envie de reprendre ma
vie attendz à ver là bien sûr bien sûr
bien sûr
évidemment je remercie la cour de pas
nous avoir fait trop attendre trop
longtemps mais Olivier aostache ne va
pas souffler longtemps car 3 jours plus
tard le parqué de nanter fait appel de
cette
décision un nouveau procès se tiendra
d'ici 1
an l'énigme de la mort de Dominique auri
n'est pas encore définitivement
levé